ucrania ha podido empezar hoy con las
exportaciones de trigo y grano que
habían sido bloqueados en los puertos
del mar negro de ucrania desde la
invasión rusa en febrero de este mismo
año rusia estableció un bloqueo naval en
los puertos y créanos que vieron como
sus contenidos sobre todo de trigo y
grano
eran bloqueados ucrania en ucrania la
actualidad a cerca de 25 millones de
toneladas de trigo que esperan a ser
exportadas hoy mismo ha empezado con la
salida del puerto de odessa del barco de
razón y con bandera de sierra leona que
está transitando ahora mismo fuera del
puerto esquivando las minas marítimas
colocadas por ucrania con destino
primero a estambul donde el contenido de
este barco será investigado por la
comisión y el centro de investigación
conjunta establecido la semana pasada en
estambul junto con turquía naciones
unidas rusia y ucrania el contenido será
investigado mañana cuando llegue a
puerto de estambul este barco que
después zarpará con destino primero al
bósforo después los desechos del
dardanelos para llegar a su destino
final el puerto de trípoli en el líbano
que será liberada como el contenido de
25.000 toneladas de trigo será
descargado en un pais líbano con una
grave crisis económica y alimento y que
verá como su mercado será abastecido con
un trigo que necesitan no solo líbano
sino también toda áfrica oriente medio y
asia